i think no one more than me wants to get
back to in-person meetings because for
me this is a relationship business and
that's why i love what i do that's why i
love getting up every morning and you
know coming to work because i love
having
these meaningful conversations
[Music]
jennifer gross thank you so much for
being on my show 20 minute leaders how
are you
wonderful michael thank you i'm so happy
to be here today i'm i'm very excited to
hear about
fundraising about american friends for
television university the great work
that you're doing there and really
getting into the mindset of what it
means to
to be that helpful for both the research
institution but
i believe it's israel's largest uh
university right in terms of
more than 30 000 students that's correct
we are israel's largest university and
covering
basically every discipline you can think
of okay so i'm excited to learn more
about television university in itself
but i'd love to start with a little bit
about you
coming all the way from investment
banking and i understand that you have
quite a bit of experience with
fundraising over the years
so i i obviously you're you're the
perfect person for this job but
tell me a little bit about yourself all
the way from northeastern how do you
make your way
towards the financial world to get to be
the ceo
of this great organization and this
non-profit
so you're right i started actually at
northwestern
i started there um and graduated
went to work for morgan stanley as an
investment banking analyst and did that
program for two years
concluding that program i moved to
institutional money management marketing
the u.s equity product of a company that
was a wholly owned sub
of credit suisse and uh from there
was home with my two children now 23 and
25 year olds for 10 years
during that time i got very involved in
non-profit
and i guess as a proxy for working
professionally
and needing to have my own time i got
very involved volunteering so i took on
all kinds of
volunteer roles but the common theme
throughout those roles was really
it was about raising money and my
feeling was kind of where the rubber
hits the road
in order to help the people it's about
the money so i guess i sort of cut my
teeth in
fundraising as a volunteer for many
different organizations
are our synagogue my children's school
some israeli organizations
federation in new york city
and spent about 10 years doing that and
as my children got older they're
they were in jewish day school so their
day was pretty long
and i became clear to me that they
didn't really need me at home anymore
at sort of at the end of my time being
home with them
they between after school activities and
play dates with friends they were sort
of busy until seven o'clock at night so
i saw that
this was really my opportunity to be
able to go back to work
but before i continue i need to
understand a little bit about the
context of fundraising
what does it mean to to raise funds
because i'm coming from the startup
world from the venture capital world
where it's very obvious what fundraising
is it's a it's
more of a transactional type of deal
it's a partnership that we're going to
also expect a return but the type of
fundraising that that you're dealing
with
doesn't necessarily expect a monetary
return so
talk to me about the what is the process
of raising funds
as a non-profit so for me fundraising is
is really a relationship build it's all
about relationship building
it's you know michael you're a
philanthropist and you're looking to
achieve certain goals philanthropically
and how
are we tel aviv university best in class
partners for you to achieve that
right so it's really having a
conversation and getting to know
the potential donor and what moves him
or her
and what they care about and again how
we can help them
realize or hopefully even exceed what
they're trying to do so the return while
you're right it's not
i sort of got my start in fundraising
raising money for hedge funds from
institutions and you're absolutely right
with transactional and they were looking
you know to generate a certain return to
be able to to meet their
their you know their needs and this is
very different this is really about
speaking to people who are
philanthropically inclined and who
want to who have certain measures that
they want to achieve and really
either helping them zone in on exactly
what that is or how to do it
okay so it sounds to me that there are a
few different verticals here one of them
is the
people that are already considering
themselves philanthropic they're known
as philanthropists and
then you're finding some sort of
alignment between your mission their
mission and then it's a win-win
situation
but i'm sure there are also people that
are not yet considered philanthropists
but they may have the the means to
contribute
they may have missions that are aligned
and you're also tasked with trying to
find those people
and explain to them what philanthropy
could be right
you're absolutely right so that's you
know that that that oftentimes is a
longer lead time because that's not just
talking to you
someone who cares about certain you know
to achieve certain things
philanthropically but that's talking to
you about really
you know sort of that's a that's a much
larger conversation about values
what you value what's important to you
what sort of legacy or what sort of
impact you're looking to have for people
who aren't yet philanthropic but
to your point have the ability to be
philanthropic it's really a conversation
of sort of
why is this why is this the right thing
to do why is this the appropriate thing
for you to do at this stage of your life
you know why
you why not somebody else and and and
how can you feel so good about what
you're doing and what you're making
possible and the impact that you're
having on others
which can seem sort of counter-intuitive
to you know iron the money it's my money
so sometimes there's a little bit of a
of a golf that you have to
do you have to transcend in terms of of
why
being philanthropic is appropriate and
not even just appropriate but is really
extraordinarily uplifting so so how so
why does a person become philanthropic
you're saying it's extremely rewarding
uplifting
but i don't i don't think it's that
obvious right to the average person why
spending money or or donating money is
automatically
you know and a rewarding enriching
experience so why does one become
philanthropic and what does one gain out
of
out of it because it is a two-sided
street
one becomes philanthropic i guess for
one of two reasons one
is they really feel like
i've been given certain assets and
certain resources
and giving back is either something
that i want to do or i feel is my
responsibility to do
um or you know is the right thing to do
right so so sort of internally motivated
the external motivation
is sometimes about really introducing
this person or people to the needs and
and and to sort of the broader landscape
out there
um and and i think
pointing out the the needs the
opportunities and the impact that's
that's possible um because in my
experience i've seen that
uh when you see look private
philanthropy can is
is dwarfed by by governmental spending
but governmental spending there are
tremendous holes and there are
governments
institutions tend to like to fund
specific projects
but without having the lights on and the
staff paid and the you know the copy
machine serviced
you cannot run those programs so i think
when
people can see assuming someone either
is
or is willing to become
philanthropically minded when people can
see
what private philanthropy can make
possible
it becomes sort of addicting and you
realize the impact when you really get
to meet the grantees or to see the
programs and to see what it is that you
can make possible
everybody loves spending on themselves
and their families and trips and homes
or whatever it is but this is totally
different and for those who have i think
um there's a real argument to be made
about
or i should say the way that we've
raised our children is sort of the
measure to which you have is the measure
to which you have a responsibility to
give back i love that i love that and i
have to say
growing up in both in palo alto tel aviv
i'm i'm right now a student at stanford
while also senior associate at j
ventures and at the start of hippo
i'm surrounded by people that are very
very motivated and ambitious
and a lot of these people are excited to
go into the startup scene potentially to
be
going towards an exit strategy or
running a public company a very
successful one
or alternatively going into investment
banking or other
venture capital types of funds
all of which have high potential for
making a lot of money and when i ask
them
you know what with the motivation behind
that money very rarely do i hear
i want to be a philanthropist when i'm
older right i want to be at london
i'm seeing you know the work that that a
lot of the brilliant people like
like the top tech leaders that they're
spending
large sometimes large chunks of their
money on on having positive impact on
the world
and i can't help but get excited about
potentially if i do get a chance to
to have means for myself to be able to
contribute as well it sounds like a
fantastic impact but jennifer tell me a
little bit about
tel aviv university what you're doing
there from the united states
i believe you're one of the biggest
donors to tell you
or the or the groups that are channeling
funds towards top of university right
we are the largest donor to the
university our support
we raise uh i would say around 35
million dollars a year
which we send to is to israel to
university
we're number one say
that uh in addition to us being number
one israel is number two
so the israeli philanthropic community
while it's
younger and and more sort of in its
infancy
has really and you've started to see
israelis with real means start to give
um so we're proud that that we're first
and that israel is second i think that's
something really significant israelis
are seeing
the potential and are investing in their
university in the same way that
you know americans are investing in
their universities so i think that's
that's critical it's something that i
haven't had since i was at northwestern
and to get to
the deans and the professors and the
researchers and
you know working in the labs and and
doing the kind of cutting edge
work and innovation it's it's just so
generative and it's something that's so
exciting and
i think it empowers all of us
at the american friends to be able to
tell the story and to really try to
convey what's going on in the excitement
and the possibilities not just for
changing
what's going on in israel on the ground
but really the the the
the ripple effect of the technology and
the innovation and the discoveries
at the university are really rippling
out worldwide and that's something
that's
that's extraordinary and when you speak
to somebody about about
about giving money and about being
philanthropic especially when you speak
to someone in any
aspect of the financial services
industry whether that's hedge funds or
whether that's
the you know startups or venture or
angel
or private equity and sort of anywhere
in financial services i think everyone's
looking for
impact and one of the exciting things
about
investing in israel and and not to say
this is at the expense of anyone
investing in their universities in the
us but the sort of the purchasing power
of a dollar in israel versus in the u.s
is just exponential so we
tell the university was fortunate uh
that we were doing collaborations
through the correct foundation with
stanford and so
you know it's not one to one one
researcher from stanford one from tel
aviv it's
one to six so if you're philanthropic
and if you're thinking about the impact
and what your funds can do and how they
can
farther you know that's that's
definitely something that we've seen we
have somebody who
has been giving multiple millions of
dollars for cancer research in the us
um and he just gave to tel aviv
university because
the ability to have an impact and for
those research dollars to go even
further exist in israel
in a way that it doesn't exist here i
think that's just wrong
but but going to the beginning why does
the university
need to raise funds why does the
university need
millions of dollars in order to operate
it's a great question because you ask
yourself you're the biggest university
in israel you're a public university
like why isn't that the government's
responsibility it's a great
question and they would tell you that it
is the government's responsibility and
the amount of money that the government
gives the us is
sorry the amount of money that the
government gives the university
is it it far exceeds any other sources
of funds
and that those funds that funding level
gets the university to good
television university would be a good
university they would have you know
they'd have access to good researchers
and good equipment
but not great the difference from good
to great the way that we're able to
reverse the brain drain and to bring all
the postdocs who go out of israel
because they have to to do the postdoc
work that's going to be uh
really respected in academia to be able
to bring them back and to be able to
give them
enough lab equipment and access to post
docs
all that that's really private
philanthropy that's where private
philanthropy comes in so in order for
the university to do all it can do for
israel and for the world
it's dependent on private philanthropy
wow so so
so it makes perfect sense the donations
are what's bringing good to great
and obviously when i'm when i'm even
trying to start comparing the
endowment or the funds that a place like
stanford or harvard or mit have compared
to
the numbers that you that you said
before you know it's literally adding
zeros
at the end it's uh which is which is
pretty remarkable then considering that
television university and other
universities in israel
do such cutting-edge technology and we
have some of the brightest people in the
world so
it's just it's just phenomenal what does
your day-to-day look like
you and your team as you're working
towards helping
tel aviv from the united states are we
talking about pre-pandemic or
post-pandemic
oh i have to hear both so pre-pandemic
when i started i set a goal for myself
which was in the first year to get out
and meet all the members of our board
and the members the university has a
board of governors to meet the members
the board have got the the members of
the board of governors from the us
and to meet our major donors so i would
say my day-to-day
until march was basically on a plane
probably more often than not getting to
getting to san francisco to la to
chicago to miami
all over to israel to really meet people
and really
understand sort of their relationship to
the university and opportunities and
just
just really fill them in also what we
were doing and that was a real focus
um well then sort of covet hit and
everything had to pivot and so i would
say that we took the opportunity
when i when i joined in my role there
had been
sort of a gap for 10 months there was no
ceo they had a ceo search on and so
when i started it became clear that we
really needed some internal
planning um and structure in order to be
as strong of an institution as we could
be so
when the pandemic hit we took advantage
of the opportunity
or the lack of opportunity to travel and
to have face-to-face meetings and really
looked internally
and started a strategic planning process
where we came up with an overall
organizational strategic plan
a fundraising plan a communications plan
where we really designed
with regards to the fundraising team we
designed what are
their pipelines going to look like and
how are we going to structure you know
their sort of workflow
um we we really took on looking at all
of our communications and all of our
materials and how do we want to change
that so we did the sort of internal
processes
and planning that um have served us well
and i think
when things do open up we'll really will
be able to come out strong
wow that's just amazing and so what does
the future
hold for american friends of tel aviv
university
or for fundraising for universities in
general
which is the future whole the future
holds i think no one more than me wants
to get back to in-person meetings
because for me this is a relationship
business and that's why i love what i do
that's why i love getting up every
morning
and you know coming to work because i
love having these meaningful
conversations and
i'm fortunate that sort of where i am in
my career
the conversations are really with people
who are for the most part
philanthropically inclined
and certainly have the means so it's so
it's an it's an exciting it's an
interesting it's
always a meaningful conversation um so
so i think the so so i'm hopeful we get
back to that
i think in terms of um in terms of the
near term
it looks a lot like trying to
simulate or give people a similar
feeling to being in someone's living
room and hearing from a cutting edge
researcher
or someone who's doing cutting age
innovation trying to use the technology
that we have
to make it more interactive and after
the pandemic hit and we all went into
lockdown we began doing weekly webinars
which then
in the last couple months became every
other week but i think
people have gotten you know zoom fatigue
and
of course people want to connect and so
i think ways that we can
connect people in smaller groups or
or or more around more specific
interests
i think that's exciting 100 no i think
that i think that's
it's very exciting and i'm very hopeful
that it goes back to reality as soon as
possible jennifer thank you for taking
the time to do this
and before we finish i need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
it's very tough to boil oneself down to
three words i would say
i would say my three words in
alphabetical order because i'm not sure
i would have to think longer about how
to organize them otherwise
are caring hard-working
and positive it sounds like those are
three things that you definitely need as
you're
going about the mission that you're
doing and and i think that it's
inspiring for me
looking at your background going all the
way from investment banking and those
financial institutions and making your
way towards philanthropy and really
making an impact and
and i haven't really even thought of
that about a dollar invested in in a
place like television university versus
the dollar spent
in many other places it's a different
impact uh
it's not to say that it's it's better or
worse but it's a different impact
and and it sounds very very exciting
that you are making a very positive
impact so thank you very much
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
you too